what up fellow space cowboy goes in here
for anime uproar in today we're going to
be talking about the best geniuses in
anime aka the most entertaining geniuses
in anime this is not like those lists
that list off the smartest anime
characters because you can be insanely
smart on paper and not be that
interesting in practice for instance
think of Alakazam who has an IQ of 5,000
Alakazam has a way higher IQ than
Shikamaru from Naruto who has an IQ over
200 but Shikamaru actually uses his
brains to come up with impressive and as
a result entertaining strategies it is
these kinds of intelligent strategies
that got me hooked on anime in the first
place when I was a kid I liked anime
like Pokemon Digimon and Dragon Ball Z
without ever knowing they were anime
however I might have stopped watching
anime if my friend in high school didn't
introduce me to the Naruto manga
I still remember reading it in class I
was reading about the Chunin exams and I
fell in love with the strategy involved
in the battles it wasn't just about
overpowering the other person it was
more about outsmarting them and I'd
never really been exposed to anything
like that before and to be honest I
think it's a huge shame that Naruto
ended up becoming so much more powerful
than his peers because that meant that
as we progress in the story strategy
became less important than power
but before Naruto gained godlike power
we had the glorious Chunin exams and we
got to witness Shikamaru in action who
is the first genius I want to talk about
Shikamaru is my favorite character in
Naruto I love how he's relatively weak
and lazy and yet when the chips are down
he can use his mind to find a way to
succeed in almost any situation
I love how almost everyone had grand
ambitions like becoming Hokage and in
contrast Shikamaru just wanted to be an
average ninja making an average living
he wanted to marry a regular girl who's
not super pretty or ugly have two kids a
girl and then a boy he wanted to retire
when his kid successfully became ninja
and then just spent the rest of his days
playing shogi he dreamed of a carefree
and leisurely retirement Shikamaru
always stood out because of his
intelligence and different view of the
world it also helps that he's so good at
shogi because we know that anyone good
at shogi or chess is a complete boss and
I'm totally not just saying that
I love playing chess and watching the
shogi based anime March comes in like a
lion anyways even after just learning to
play the game Shikamaru can beat his
sensei Asuma at shogi but what's really
interesting to me is how Shikamaru uses
his brains to come up with strategies in
battle let's take a look at his fight
against clone su Chi during the Chunin
exams from the beginning his opponent
underestimates him she calls his shadow
technique stupid if you didn't know
Shikamaru starts at a disadvantage
because she knows she Kumar's abilities
and he doesn't know hers Shikamaru ends
up using her needle string attacks to
catch her in his shadow jutsu that's a
good first step but as his opponent
points out and I quote while we're
locked into this mimicry any injury done
to me will hurt you too so it seems like
Shikamaru cannot really take her out
without taking himself out then we get
the great and unexpected finale it
appears like Shikamaru is going to make
her and him take damage from shuriken
until one of them is no longer fit for
battle but he dodges last minute you
might think that would mean they both
simply avoided the attack but Shikamaru
was using the terrain to his advantage
his opponent was close to the wall and
when he threw his head back her head hit
hard into the wall taking her out of
commission
what's so entertaining about this match
is that shikamaru's opponent never saw
what was coming she never saw the big
picture she continually underestimated
Shikamaru talking as if her victory was
assured
in contrast Shikamaru acted like he
didn't know what was going on even
though he was several steps ahead of her
the entire time he wasn't really
stronger than his opponent but he
outsmarted her he was planning ahead and
she unknowingly followed along as he
dictated the direction of the match even
when he seemingly loses Shikamaru wins
during his fight with tamati we get to
witness more of shikamaru's intellect he
says he doesn't really care whether he
becomes a Chunin or not but he can't
stand the idea of losing to a girl he
quickly uses his kunai in an
unconventional way in order to dodge
Tammany's attack he sticks his kunai
into the wall and stands on top of them
to avoid any damage instead of being
fired up as most people are he just
wishes he wasn't fighting a girl
he envies the clouds for being so free
this totally reminds me of when I had to
write a bunch of essays and take a bunch
of exams in University and I envied the
geese I saw because they were free to
bathe in the Sun swim in the water enjoy
the moment and not worry about any of
that human stuff another reason I can
relate to Shikamaru anyways Shikamaru
ends up taking the fight more or less
seriously he tries to capture tamati
with his shadow but she dodges it and
notices there's a limit to how much his
shadow can stretch across a sunlit area
other shadows add to that distance but
in a sunlit area it seems she can only
extend 50 meters and 32 centimeters then
Shikamaru take suppose he takes when
he's stuck and needs to plot his
strategy I love the fact that Shikamaru
drops everything and just begins to
meditate in the middle of battle soon
enough Shikamaru has a plan he tries to
get her again with his shadow
he bought time so that the shadow in the
arena would be bigger and he could use
his shadow beyond the area that tamari
marked off as the shadows limit yet
she's quick enough to dodge it again
then Shikamaru uses his shirt headband
and kunai to create a kind of parachute
that creates a shadow on the field and
extends the shadow by getting Tamara to
focus on the ground he kept her from
noticing the parachute tamati being a
good strategist herself may just to
still anticipate and dodge shikamaru's
shadow
however as Quinn and I mentioned
Shikamaru was steps ahead the whole time
the larger arena shadow the parachute
they were just used as distractions so
that Shikamaru could pushed him any
closer to the hole that Naruto created
during the last match
he used the tunnel between the two holes
to extend his shadow and get Tamara
while she was distracted by his other
shadow he won the game of shadow tag but
Shikamaru gives up the match he planned
out about 200 more moves but his shadow
possession is about to run out because
he's used too much chakra so he's out of
time yet most experienced people don't
see shikamaru's loss as a weakness they
praise his ability to keep a calm head
and they deduce that if Shikamaru had a
team as ninja wood during a mission he
would have easily won he has proven that
he has the disposition of a natural
leader and thus he is the only one
who becomes a Chunin instead of getting
the anticipated Sasuke and Gaara fight
after Naruto's we had to watch Shikamaru
and tamari instead everyone in the
audience and some of the readers too
were probably upset at first
however Shikamaru managed to make this
side fight one of the most interesting
wants in the show and by the end of it I
was totally satisfied with it I don't
think anyone else ever lost in such a
victorious way
tamati went from being frightened that
he captured her to shock that he gave up
to impress that he managed to outsmart
her
in contrast Shikamaru was completely
cool-headed
even as he forfeited the match and even
ended up being promoted to Chunin while
no one else did including tamati
forfeiting the match was a necessary
sacrifice so that he could get the
checkmate aka become a Chunin which was
the whole point of the Chunin exams it
is no wonder that tamari caught feelings
for this lazy genius next let's talk
about light from Death Note a smart
student who finds a notebook of death
there are a bunch of rules surrounding
the Death Note but the main idea is that
he can kill people if he writes their
names into Death Note while he pictures
their face in his mind while light is
using the Death Note to try and become
the god of a new and ideal world l
secretly the number one number two and
number three detective in the world is
trying to catch him i watch Death Note
soon after I got into Naruto and I was
hooked on anime ever since the
intellectual battle between light and L
in Death Note blew me away when I first
watched it in a way that nothing else
I watched before or since ever did I'll
talk about L in another video if you
guys want a part two to this one but I
want to cover light in this one because
I sometimes feel like he gets less love
compared to L by the way if you guys do
want a part too make sure to smash that
like button and leave a comment listing
some of your favorite geniuses and anime
that you'd like me to cover but back to
light it will sometimes the little
things that really impressed me and
stuck with me I absolutely loved how he
tended to be so careful with the things
he did especially earlier on in the
series Death Note takes a seemingly
mundane act and makes it as epic as any
battle Shonen lights explanation of how
he knew someone who wasn't
family had been in his room was
absolutely fascinating to me at the time
you see when he closes his door
his doorknob straightens up he usually
keeps his doorknob slightly down so that
he'll know if someone enters his room
because when he comes back it will be
back to its straight position this is
cool on its own but light takes it a
step further
really the doorknob is just a red
herring it's there to mislead anyone who
enters his room he also keeps some
pencil led on the door hinge so someone
goes in that pencil led will break
because of this broken pencil and he
knows that not only did someone enter
his room it also had to be someone who
wasn't a family member since his family
members wouldn't go out of their way to
return the door hinge to a slightly down
position he used this little trick to
figure out that his room is probably
bugged and knows immediately not to
speak to Ryu yet he doesn't lose his
cool for even a second you'd have no
idea if you were watching him that light
made such a huge discovery just to give
you a sense of how into Death Note I was
at the time a 13 year old me put pencil
it on my door hinge for a little bit
until I realized that no one has any
reason to enter my room then there is
the famous potato chip eating scene this
has got to be one of the most epic
moments in anime period keep in mind
light needs the spuddy while he's
secretly killing people and acting like
a quote-unquote normal teenager because
if his grades drop people will start to
get suspicious first off I just want to
say I appreciate this yes light is like
always at the top of his class
but it's not some BS where he's just
super smart and he never has to study
the death no creators make it clear that
yes light is smart but he's
realistically smart he's talented but he
studies a lot as well and that's how he
gets good marks as someone who also got
good marks from high school through to
my master's degree I appreciate the fact
that the creators recognized that it
does take time and work to produce good
grades perhaps it's a tiny detail but it
was definitely not lost on me
so while light is making sure he studies
sleeps looks put together tries to look
normal and tries to avoid slipping up
while he's under cost'
surveillance in his own home the
potato-chip scene takes place l suspects
that light may be Kira and he's watching
him closely light knows this so how can
he make it look like he's not Kira well
one way is to kill off criminals whose
images appeared on live TV while light
was clearly not watching TV so light
turns off the TV and studies however
he's eating chips as he does it and
unbeknownst to L there's a little
portable TV in the bag of chips
of course light knowing where the
cameras are has made it so that the
cameras would not be able to see what's
actually in the bag he appears to be
just eating chips but he's actually
using a small piece of the Death Note
and a small pencil inside of the bag to
write the names of the criminals showing
up on the small portable TV screen all
the wild dramatic music is playing in
the background making the scene feel
epic and intense and in fact it is epic
and intense to ellen lights that it
looks like light is just studying and
eating chips while kira is killing
criminals but in reality light is
killing those people when light says
I'll take a potato chip and eat it it's
one of the most thrilling lines of the
series on the one hand it seems like
he's just eating a potato chip but on
the other hand he's murdering people in
front of his rival Elle's very eyes and
he's completely getting away with it for
someone who has an ego as big as lights
this is the height of satisfaction
he's outsmarting his rival he's winning
the most important battle of his life
while eating potato chips
imagine you were in a fight against the
best fighter in the world and you were
eating potato chips and still kicking
his butt that's how light feels right
now then he act normal
throws out the chip bag with the
expensive portable TV and eventually
watches it get destroyed by the garbage
truck the evidence that he's killed
anyone is completely gone he managed to
pull off murder in front of the number
one number two and number three
detective in the world and he got away
with it there are many more moments of
Lights brilliance but I wanted to focus
on how tampering with a door and eating
potato chips can become insanely
interesting more
interesting then in life-or-death
physical battle when done right that's
the power of a well-written genius
lastly I want to talk about Lelouch from
Code Geass long story short Lelouch is a
rebel genius trying to take down a
corrupt government using his super power
which takes the form of a Geass his
Geass if he can make direct eye contact
allows him to command people to do
anything but it only works once so as
you can see there are limitations as
with a Death Note
without Lelouch is brains his Geass
would not be as useful or as
entertaining Lelouch is extremely good
at chess and that's part of the reason
louche was my favorite anime character
after I first watched koji AHS it was
another anime that hooked me over the
course of the first few episodes but
what especially stuck with me where his
battles against now another Geass user
you seem a little usha script tonight
the louche can practically beat anyone
in chess and outsmart them in battle by
thinking several moves ahead not to
mention he has the benefit of his Geass
power except this gets complicated when
Mao enters the equation Mao can read
Lelouch his mind
so it seems Lelouch can no longer think
several moves ahead of his opponent as
far ahead as he plans Mao can follow his
thought process and beat him since he
always knows what's coming
mouse powers can work beyond a certain
distance but when they are sitting down
together playing chess Lelouch doesn't
stand a chance when Mao reveals that he
no see - who is Aleutians much more
attractive Ryu Lelouch instantly comes
up with fourteen possible identities for
Mao and one of them is right now is a
Geass user who previously had contact
with c2 he is obsessed with c2 and wants
her all to himself
despite the cards being stacked against
him Lelouch figures out a way to beat
mal not once but twice and both times I
loved how Lelouch managed so smart-mouth
in the first case Mao kidnaps c2 and
takes her to an amusement park
now Lelouch knows that if he just gets
within a certain range of mao mao will
be able to read his thoughts and see him
coming so he comes up with a plan he
records himself talking to mao and plays
the recordings on the amusement park
screens as
Lucia explains the MAL leader mouse
thoughts are far too simple because he
uses his mind-reading as a crutch thus
more or less Lelouch was able to predict
what Mao would say and keep him from
discovering that it was just a recording
while Mao was distracted by what he
mistook to be Lelouch is livestream
Lelouch kiosks a bunch of cops and
brought them to take out mal mal needs
to concentrate to increase his range of
mind-reading
so because mal was distracted by the
recording he didn't see it coming
hence Lelouch found a way to turn mouths
Geass against him as a cherry on top of
the cake Lelouch even predicted that mal
would try to reveal that Lelouch is zero
after he lost and so he made that the
signal for the cops to shoot him somehow
Mao survives
apparently Lelouch told the cops to
shoot him rather than kill him
so through Britannia and medical science
Mao comes back to fight in the next
episode is it pretty unrealistic della
louche would make such a mistake and
that mal would be fine after so many
gunshots yeah it is but I'm not even mad
because of how entertaining the second
battle is I even preferred it to the
first mal comes back smarter and more
cautious because he has more experience
fighting again solution now if you know
anything about Lelouch you know that his
little sister Natalie is a single most
important person in his life his whole
goal of creating a more just world
sprang from his love for her so what
does Mao do he kidnaps her this time
this time Lelouch is everything is on
the line
now put nominally close to a bomb if he
wins a chess match against the louche
the bomb will go off and if Lelouch wins
the bomb will be disarmed so in order to
win
Lelouch needs do the impossible win a
chess match against someone who can read
his every thought this part of the
series is insanely intense Lelouch is
losing he begs for Natalie's life he
admits that he lost he means it too
because if he didn't Mao would be able
to tell we've never seen Lelouch so
worried and utterly defeated but Mao has
no mercy he goes to throw Lelouch his
final chess piece into the mechanism
that
detonate the bomb and kill non-elite the
lucious whole face contorts and he
screams out we get to see what he acts
like when he's lost everything important
to him however the louche was actually
one step ahead of mao again even though
he didn't even know it at the time not
only is fine and Suzaku comes in dodged
some bullets like it's nothing and
disarms mal then Lelouch realizes that
he gave Suzaku instructions and used his
Geass power on himself using a mirror so
he'd forget
thus he came up with the plan that would
defeat mal and then erased his memories
so he and by extension mal
wouldn't know about the back-up plan
sometimes Code Geass sacrifices realism
for entertainment but that's not
necessarily a bad thing it's one of my
favorite anime of all time and if you
haven't I strongly suggest that you
watch it watching the lucious
intelligence strategies play out alone
makes it a show worth binging and Aldo
Lelouch doesn't always act as
intelligent and cautious as light and
has no comparable L counterpart I do
prefer his character arc to light and
that is it for today's video if you
enjoyed the video make sure to smash
that like one to let me know if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
vital ring that notification bell for
more videos like this one let me know in
the comments if you want to see a part
two to this video and let me know who
your favorite genius and anime is and
which of their genius moments really
stood out to you a big thank you goes
out to our patrons over on patreon who
help make videos like this one possible
I especially want to thank our pro hero
tier patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
baby ray nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
King's eldest and angel crews and are
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
atop all clans a17 ffvp Steven and Greta
allo law and attempt Maddie Mac 239
makoto-kun and Kela and the patrons who
transcend greatness itself Regan
Harrison and Lord naksan or the chosen
few who have been acknowledged by Lord
Twigg o himself if you enjoy our work
you can support more of it by going over
to patreon calm
and becoming a patron today for as
little as $1 if you do so you'll get
your name featured in future videos
alongside these geniuses right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron Olney discord
so check out patreon.com/lenguin
[Music]